Bien sûr, vous voulez qu'il apprenne à marcher si
tôt, eh bien, il a presque un an.
désolé, nous
célébrons la victoire de votre roi à New
York, nous sommes le phare de l'autorité et
nous portons le fardeau de cette autorité
que faites-vous ici j'ai vu Ben
Tallmadge a essayé de me recruter pour une
mission sacrée contre les Britanniques je
veux pourquoi  pas
salut Baberaham Woodall, de quoi ont-ils
besoin de plus pour prendre des photos ?
Je ne peux pas me permettre de te perdre c'était impressionnant Je sais que tu as menti Je ne te protège pas
ils ont des espions partout
nous avons besoin de la même chose tout ce que je demande c'est que tu te
battes pour ce en quoi tu crois
personne d'autre ne connaît mon nom  e Non,
je pense que tu sais quelque chose, mais je pense que
tu veux me dire que
cette érection est une charge sérieuse
qu'attends-tu pour
rester aussi loin que possible de
ça, je le
ferai, tout le monde dit bonjour